escuchamos la frase igual disuelve a
igual
cuando hablamos de solubilidad esta idea
nos ayuda a predecir la solubilidad de
los compuestos por ejemplo un solvente
polar puede disolver a un compuesto
polar y también un solvente polar puede
disolver un soluto iónico después
tenemos que un solvente no polar puede
disolver compuestos no polares igual
disuelve a igual y por eso un solvente
polar no puede disolver a un compuesto
no polar un ejemplo de solvente polar es
el agua y un ejemplo de solvente no
polar podría ser el aceite y sabemos que
no podemos disolver aceite en agua pero
regresemos a la primera idea de que un
solvente polar puede disolver un
compuesto polar o un compuesto iónico
como el cloruro de sodio sabemos que él
cloruro de sodio o sal de mesa es
soluble en agua del lado izquierdo
tenemos una parte del cristal sabemos
que los cristales se unen por fuerzas de
atracción la carga positiva del cat ión
de sodio es atraída a la carga negativa
de la unión cloruro cargas opuestas se
atraen y tenemos fuerzas de atracción en
todo el cristal si ponemos algunas
moléculas de agua a su alrededor sabemos
que el agua es una molécula polar el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno retira densidad electrónica de
este enlace lo que le da una carga
parcial negativa así que el hidrógeno
tiene una carga parcial positiva y como
las cargas opuestas se atraen el
hidrógeno parcialmente positivo en el
agua es
por la carga negativa de lannion cloruro
hay una interacción y si tenemos más
moléculas de agua aquí tenemos otra
parcial negativo y parcial positivo aquí
hay otra fuerza de atracción entre más
fuerzas podemos sacar el año en cloruro
del cristal hacia la solución del lado
derecho
tenemos el año en cloruro en solución
rodeado de un montón de moléculas de
agua y tenemos todos estos hidrógenos
parcialmente positivos interactuando con
el año en cloruro cargado negativamente
por otra parte regresemos a nuestro
sólido de la izquierda como el camión de
sodio está cargado positivamente
entonces puede interaccionar con la
carga negativa del oxígeno en la
molécula de agua y si tenemos
suficientes moléculas de agua podemos
jalar a los cationes de sodio hacia la
solución aquí tenemos todos estos
oxígenos parcialmente negativos del agua
interactuando con el cat ión de sodio
entonces nuestro solvente polar el agua
ataca al cristal es decir al sólido y
reemplaza las interacciones entre iones
dentro del cristal con interacciones y
un dipolo en la solución con ion dipolo
me refiero a que tenemos un guión y
nuestro tipo lo es el agua porque es una
molécula polar y podemos decir que tiene
un momento dipolar así que tenemos todas
estas interacciones y un dipolo por
estas interacciones los solutos iónicos
se disuelven en agua y si tuviéramos un
compuesto polar es la misma idea las
fuerzas de atracción permiten que los
compuestos polares se puedan disolver en
un solvente polar
como el agua ahora veamos un compuesto
no polar esta molécula es un ejemplo de
compuesto no polar se conoce como
naftalina la naftalina es un sólido con
un aroma muy particular la naftalina es
no polar porque solo se compone de
carbonos e hidrógeno es un hidrocarburo
entonces al ser no polar
necesitamos un solvente no polar para
poder disolverlo y el tolueno es un
solvente no polar es un hidrocarburo
entonces si tenemos naftalina que es un
sólido y tolueno que es un líquido la
naftalina podrá disolverse en tolueno
nuestro solvente no polar puede disolver
un compuesto no polar
finalmente analicemos esta idea de que
un solvente polar como por ejemplo el
agua no puede disolver a un compuesto no
polar como la naftalina
eso es cierto la naftalina no se puede
disolver en agua así que el agua no
puede interactuar con moléculas de
naftalina para formar una solución
entonces el concepto de igual disuelve a
igual es muy importante porque nos ayuda
a predecir si un compuesto será soluble
en agua
ahora veamos algunos compuestos
orgánicos y determinemos si son solubles
en agua empecemos con etanol el etanol
tiene un enlace polar oxígeno hidrógeno
porque el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno y retira
densidad electrónica lo que le da al
oxígeno una carga parcial negativa y al
hidrógeno una carga parcial positiva si
una molécula de agua entra la dibujaré
por aquí sabemos que el agua es un
solvente polar el oxígeno es
parcialmente negativo y el hidrógeno es
parcialmente positivo observen que hay
una atracción el hidrógeno parcialmente
positivo del etanol es atraído por el
oxígeno parcialmente negativo del agua
este es un ejemplo de enlaces o fuentes
de hidrógeno que vimos anteriormente en
otros vídeos y podemos tener más enlaces
de hidrógeno si ponemos otra molécula de
agua la dibujaré por aquí sabemos que el
oxígeno es parcialmente negativo y el
hidrógeno es parcialmente positivo
nuevamente tenemos una interacción entre
el oxígeno parcialmente negativo del
etanol y el hidrógeno parcialmente
positivo del agua entonces esta parte de
la molécula de etanol es polar y le
gusta el agua podemos decir que esta
parte es hidrofílico ama el agua
pero veamos la otra parte de la molécula
del lado izquierdo
tenemos un ch 2 y un ch 3
sólo tenemos carbonos e hidrógeno
eso significa que esta parte es no polar
no le gusta el agua es hidrofóbica
hidrofóbica
entonces sabemos que el etanol es
soluble en agua eso significa que la
parte hidrofóbica de la molécula no es
tan fuerte como la parte hidrofílica la
parte polar y eso es suficiente para que
el etanol pueda ser soluble en agua si
pensamos en esto pero ahora con otra
molécula aquí tenemos 1 octanos y como
tenemos este o h puede ocurrir la misma
situación que con el etanol porque
tenemos una parte de la molécula que es
polar pero aquí la diferencia es que
tenemos una cadena muy larga de carbonos
que es la parte hidrofóbica es decir no
polar al ser muy grande
esta parte hace que toda la molécula sea
no polar así que el 1 octanos no se
puede disolver en agua y el etanol si se
puede disolver en agua
ahora echemos un vistazo alsina mal de
ido aquí tenemos un carbón hilo y
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el carbono
entonces el oxígeno tiene una carga
parcial negativa y el carbono en el
carbón y lo tiene una carga parcial
positiva así que esta pequeña parte de
la molécula es polar puede interactuar
con el agua sin embargo la parte no
polar es mucho más grande todo esto
corresponde a la parte hidrofóbica
entonces la parte no polar es más grande
que la polar lo que convierte al
zinemaldi ido en una molécula no polar
así que no se podrá disolver en agua
solamente se podrá disolver en solventes
no polares
ahora vamos con la sacarosa esta es una
forma de representar la observen que
tenemos varios carbonos de hidrógenos
todos estos son carbonos entonces
tenemos carbonos
e hidrógeno pero eso no significa que
este compuesto sea no polar porque
observen que también tenemos muchos
grupos o h por esa razón la sacarosa es
soluble en agua
el ácido benzoico es un sólido a
temperatura ambiente si ponemos algunos
cristales de ácido benzoico en agua a
temperatura ambiente no se van a
disolver y podemos explicarlo si
observamos la estructura del ácido
benzoico esta parte de la molécula es
polar e hidrofílica debido a la
presencia de los oxígenos pero también
tenemos esta parte que es no polar es
hidrofóbica debido a la presencia de
carbonos e hidrógeno y como los
cristales de ácido benzoico no se
disuelven en agua a temperatura ambiente
eso significa que la parte hidrofóbica
de este compuesto es más fuerte que la
parte hidrofílica pero si aumentamos la
temperatura del agua es decir la
calentamos entonces sí podemos disolver
los cristales de ácido benzoico porque
aumentamos la solubilidad del
puesto pero pensemos en los cristales de
ácido benzoico y agua a temperatura
ambiente esta vez agregaremos una base
hidróxido de sodio el hidróxido de sodio
reaccionará con el protón más ácido del
ácido benzoico el ácido benzoico donará
este protón y estos electrones en rojo
se quedarán con el oxígeno que serían
estos electrones eso le da al oxígeno
una carga formal negativa hemos formado
benzoato de sodio entonces tomamos el
protón más ácido del ácido benzoico y
formamos la base conjugado el benzoato
de sodio es muy soluble en agua a
temperatura ambiente
eso significa que aumentamos la fuerza
de la parte hidrofílica con
esta carga negativa ahora la parte
hidrofílica puede superar a la parte
hidrofóbica y por eso el benzoato de
sodio es soluble en agua porque esta
carga negativa interacciona mejor con
nuestro solvente es decir con el agua